ok today we're looking at fields we've
been doing measuring right and actually
getting out onto a field is one of the
key skills we go to year ago because one
of the key skills under mm - so here's
the idea and I draw some rough diagrams
here with me most of us think on the
field as kind of rectangular right if
you see a real result google field they
clearly it's supposed to be a rectangle
with you know 90 degrees the center I'll
get everything proper however in reality
right out in the normal world but you
don't have people spending millions of
dollars maintaining these things fields
are not victims may I enjoy this in me
as well
something like okay now we're actually
gonna do some drawings on this if you
have a rule of there that became if you
don't know you be able to do one leg up
I'm throw this opening evil for reasons
so you can see it's like it's filled ish
its rectangular ish but it's really
that's not
okay sorry okay yeah sorry bro and so
let's get back to my think about yeah
this is what this she write you down not
rectangles not rectangles but a shape
like this straight edges but none of the
edges being equal to each other we'll
call this an irregular polygon irregular
meeting all the sides of different
lengths and polygons meeting we have
straight edges now working our
measurements for these kinds of things
like the perimeter and area things you
can look out over the last week or so
it's a bit of a challenge when you've
got something that's you can't use a
formula because it's not a rectangle but
a triangle a lot of trapezium what B and
H and L are you going to put into this
thing so what we do is we have a
particular kind of diagram that helps us
break up in a regular polygon that
allows us to record the area actually
quite easily so if you have another
color there can use this instead there's
something useful if you don't have
another color that's okay I'd like you
to two drawn something similar to me I
like it
join up this diagonal it goes from the
top to the bottom like so okay all right
you can't actually join any of those
like either for diagnose but if we have
this all the same then we can now have a
similar basis
yeah yeah it's kind of often enough now
what I want to do if you recall when we
went from the formula of a rectangle to
all the other formulas we go back
parallelogram is triangles trapeze etc
you might recall that a trick we used
over and over again was to take a shape
that's weird I try and twist it into a
shape that's what's right hey remember
last lesson last two lessons we look at
area of noble figures and area of what
what was last lesson compasses shapes
right now you have a look I've just
shown that every year a poem like this
is a composition one two shapes if I got
triangles and I can deal with train was
really easily so to make it a bit
clearer off of this vertical line that
you've drawn was dying or mother I'd
like you to draw two perpendicular lines
like that which go to the corners that
aren't connected yet okay so then you
repeat that from the diagonal advice or
a perpendicular line they don't hit
these two corners which haven't been
touched yet okay so you can see my two
triangles that I've got here the left
facing one and the right facing one each
of them I can work out the area right if
you think about it I can actually and if
you've got the pencil there again I can
actually separate these out and show you
what's going on right let's do the
left-hand triangle it's gonna look like
this
so you can see if I know what that
diagonal is let's call it D for diagonal
and I can work out that perpendicular a
little bit that you just drew let's call
that H one because I'm gonna have two of
them that diagonal is the base of my
triangle and H one is the perpendicular
height it's all you need for a triangle
yep in exactly the same way I've got
this other triangle that's backing off
here on the other side so let's draw
that that base is still the same by
angle right like those two agenda
together saintly but I've just got a
different perpendicular height now I'm
not even gonna bother with the
calculations now I just want you to be
content with the fact that we can
calculate okay because we are going to
make our form diagram just like this